well let's talk uh let's talk censorship
in that capacity sure so uh many of you
probably heard youtube is now going to
remove any new videos alleging trump
lost the election because of
fraud now cnn says fraud but i actually
spoke with youtube and got some
clarification
the general ideas youtube has said
starting today
if you claim that trump lost the
election and you have to come so
actually let me start over there are two
criteria you have to meet in order to
have your videos deleted you must first
claim
that there was widespread fraud then you
must claim
it resulted in donald trump losing the
election you can say this widespread
fraud
you can say the election was stolen from
trump you can't combine these things
which is like the weirdest
nonsense but did you just do that by
explaining it yeah i'm curious well
technically no but okay they could pull
out of the context and then be like look
he said it
was that's the thing i mean tim's the
guy they want to explain it
to people yeah i guess they called me
and they were like that google actually
called me and said we want to explain to
you what this means
and they're probably hoping that i will
then convey and uh
you're not going to get a guideline
strike so if you say it they'll just
quietly remove the video
on january 21st they will give you a
guideline strike if you claim it
and they're claiming they're like we
have a long-standing policy on
historical elections that you can't
claim that fraud changed the results
therefore
it applies to this election and i'm like
this that makes no sense how can they
have a long-standing policy they haven't
existed that long
yeah or not even that like what am i
gonna do like abraham lincoln didn't
really win and like pound the table like
what yeah what about the last election
when you know the establishment
was chilling that was broad and then cnn
was always put in the algorithm to be
first no matter what you searched
regarding the election talking about how
this was not a legitimate election it
was russian collusion trump was a
russian asset
and all of that was bonked all of that
was added that was my first question
that was crap
i was like can i still say that the
russians hacked the election
and hillary clinton only lost because of
russian interference and they're like
well no i don't think so and i'm like
well i just searched it on youtube and
there's
dozens of mainstream media you know
outlets saying just that yeah if they
take down cnn for for
for violating their policy all yes it's
fair it's the right thing to do
they did take down a senate uh rand paul
speaking on the senate floor oh yeah
did you know about this no rand paul so
don't say his name he mentioned a name
that he wasn't supposed there's a name
that if i say
this live stream will be taken off here
okay so we won't say it and there's no
reason
for it is there sign language it's crazy
rand paul was talking about this
individual
okay and youtube deleted c-span the
video from c-span of rand paul on the
senate floor talking about
what was going on in our government and
why it was relevant no bias this is the
kind of stuff that should be keeping
people up at night and yet
nobody like that that's the whole thing
when we were touched on assange but the
censorship thing freaks me out
it's a big problem maybe if come
you know i we we talk about these 17
states and you know trump and they're
suing
maybe if it does end up being biden as
president
then trump supporters are when the fight
is not about trump anymore
then the as you describe it the real
left the populist left i suppose
and populist right will be mostly in
agreement about censorship being bad
i hope so look i mean i've always
they're trying to keep us apart
that's the whole point of what they're
doing if the populist left and the
populist right or the whites and the
blacks that were labor class and
everybody got together and realized that
it really is there's only two groups of
people and if you're not in charge
you're in the second group
it's a big club and you ain't doing it
exactly it's the same club they use the
beach over the head with that's george
it is and it's and it's true so like
they don't want that they love these
labels they love the infighting they
want to have you guys having audience
that hates the left they want the left
complaining about trump and the right
and they just want everybody fighting
but the reality is
is they're all just feeding their own
wallets that's all this does
but there there's a problem with uh
people on the left
who make careers off of drama channels
targeting the other targeting and the
people on the right who do the same
thing yeah
so yeah i mean what do you do to get
past that we do this like this
this is it this is what we do like
people say that to me all the time like
what do you do for this i'm like we're
doing
it but look look there's there's a bunch
of uh we've had several people on the
show who are
i guess you call them leftists or
whatever and i mean many of uh we
had destiny are you familiar with
destiny yeah he's super woke
and and he was adamantly defending
critical theory and things like that
and i completely disagree with that yeah
i think with a good conversation i think
a lot of people don't like him because
they thought that he was uh
um what's the right word i guess
disingenuous
no no no no no um arrogant kind of like
yeah
snooty to people i didn't i i don't i
don't you know like
you're talking about critical race
theory like his like the thoughts on
that
so yeah we had we we briefly described
discussed critical race theory before
the show started and he's very much in
favor of it yeah
but he says he's on the left well the
left called the dsa called him a nazi
recently so
every you mentioned the left fighting
themselves well no we eat our own we ate
our own i can't you know and
and and but i do believe that that's all
by design
because you're you're the people that
are say like you're establishment people
you're speaker of the house type people
if you will not mentioning any names
right
right so those those people that you
call the left
they want us fighting they love trump in
charge
they like all of that it serves their
corporate donors and it keeps them from
having to do anything i call it mick
resistance
that's great and that's what they are
and so they don't like me
any more than they like him because i am
an impediment to what they're doing
which is feeding their coffers good i
think that
there are a lot of people that won't
come on this show out of
i i you know what i'm not going to
speculate as to what their opinions are
but i think there's understand that
what's the deal like
you're not somebody that i think of as
like a real right wing
figure like what is the deal with that
uh
no idea you're not that scary
it's crazy i'm like one of the mo like
lukewarmest people on in political
commentary
except for luke well once you once you
come out supporting trump
then you get marked and that's really
what it is if you had a month
two months ago yeah but that's what but
that's the kind of thing that brings
attention from the left
i can't speak as to what what that was
prior to that but that's what would draw
the ire
they from the woke there was this
individual who made this study
and they're using it today to claim that
youtube is radicalizing people too far
right it's not true
because it's been debunked numerous
times there is there is nuance to this
argument but this woman created this
report
where it was a spider web of all these
channels that were like interconnected
yeah
and then i was right in the middle
that's interesting right and it's like
that's cool that means you're you're
what i call a bridge i'm the the
and and it was funny because someone
actually wrote
i think media matters was was like
smearing me and they said he was found
to be at the
center of a massive network of
right-wing radicalization
and what is this what is your mission
what are you radicalizing people to do
milk toast central news yeah i well
that's what i always say like so what's
your motive
what are you like people who because
that's a fear-based comment
you're radicalizing like to do what like
what are you
i always try to pin pinpoint people get
them to really say what it is they're
scared of because it's all fear
okay so let's assume you are doing that
okay
to to what end like what's your what's
the end game for you that
for me no i mean like no i mean like
that like but you accuse somebody of
being like yeah yeah
so so it's it's just this they want you
to send the language
right but based on what result like what
are you worried about they don't want
people watching shows like this
where we can have someone like you on
right rag on hillary clinton yeah
and then people are like yeah and all
and the truth is the people that
will be on me for that they already hate
me anyway once you have an open mind
once you stop toting the establishment
line you are a threat to them
correct and this is important to point
out here because anyone who's willing to
have a conversation anyone who's willing
to
to discuss different ideas that's not
what they want they want regurgitators
they want repeaters they want good
little prostitutes that will say
whatever the establishment wants to say
the horse stream media is a big system
that benefits off of people's ignorance
a lot of elites
a lot of powerful people make a lot of
money
get a lot of power from the ignorance of
other individuals and if you fight that
with open-mindedness they will go after
you
like like you don't know what's going on
here and going back to this topic of
censorship this is important
the way to progress a society the way to
move us forward is through an open and
honest
dialogue they are denying that to us on
so many different levels
and for them to force this kind of idea
and saying you know as there's court
cases we don't still know if there was
actual fraud or not we're still finding
out through the court proceedings
for them to declare now we're just going
to take you out is absolutely
disingenuous and horrible and propels
the larger bigger problem that people
are pointing out to and again
it affected me a couple years ago when
when i noticed my videos were just being
deleted
i remember waking up and i'm like oh
there's five videos missing i don't even
know which ones i wasn't even notified
so frog's boiling yeah more frogs in a
pot the water temperatures so the reason
why they waited till the eighth was to
create some kind of cover okay
safe harbor now we can justify the
censorship
and then you know come the 14th they'll
probably do some policy increases behind
the scenes
and then on january 20th they're gonna
start giving guidelines strikes if you
dare say
something may have happened do you ever
wonder if this has been happening all
the way along
like we're noticing it more now because
it's so like yeah i was telling people
in 2008 as soon as google gobbled up
youtube i'm like watch out guys they're
going to
suppress free speech because this is a
power a power of individuals being able
to talk to each other and resolve our
problems
resolve our differences and to
understand we're all human and not to be
dependent on this system
that's a huge threat against the
establishment and you didn't need to see
the writings on the wall to see that a
threat against the powerful
is something that they're slowly going
to make sure doesn't exist and now
they're sucking the
holy life out of it as much as they can
you know what we started seeing
is these companies that hire people to
run
multiple fake accounts to attack and
antagonize
and you'll go on reddit and you'll see
the comments and all they do is have
these generic smears against the other
but but i'll tell you i think there are
a lot of conservatives made careers off
of attacking the left
yeah so it's both ways it's both and
then they and well the left it's just a
matter of they'll call names like well
you're a russian troll
but yeah but then wouldn't anything by
design be that goes online to cause like
to wreak havoc and to like sway opinion
be equally is i mean it's all the same
thing like what
i mean any group could conceivably do
that to influence opinion or
even have money put behind that opinion
so once you have that kind of influence
to try to police that is sort of
ridiculous you know what i'm really
what really annoyed me recently was uh
alexandria ocasio-cortez
released a bunch of shirts and their
expenses yes really
she has like a like a do you mean like a
fashion like a clothing line yeah like
like
like populist left like you know dollars
shop shirts and there's
yeah eat their rage for 50 bucks but so
t-shirts their t-shirts as well like
teachers
sweaters but uh her response was they're
made in america so they're more
expensive
and the she got it she got criticized
heavily by the right for making
shirts that that poor people couldn't
afford more importantly where does the
money go
i mean probably to her campaign well no
i mean it could go to a foundation it
could go to her
it could go look and that's really where
it would come to to me like i'm an end
result person so
is she making money and giving it to
people that need money well then that's
a good thing then i really don't care
because
a aoc sweater is not an essential that
every person should be entitled to have
so i don't really care
i just don't think it's worth talking
about no so so like the reason i bring
it up is that like why are why are
people
uh and i'm not trying to single out
conservatives for protesting left
because the left doesn't all the time to
the right
there are people who make videos about
me because they make money but they're
clearly out of context manipulations
because it just generates traffic
and i wonder why it is why so many
people instead of talking about ideas
and policy and look i got no problem
talking about
ocasio ocasio-cortez in terms of the
green new deal and my disagreements with
specific provisions and things like that
but people love to just make e-drama
you know this person is ugly and they
sold a stupid shirt and well that person
is a nazi
and that's it's it's it's money for
people
but it diminishes their credibility
because it's not these are not valid
arguments it's the same thing about
the left critiquing trump for nasty
tweets
if you want to come with a criticism it
should have substance to it so there are
definitely things that one would
want to criticize aoc i generally don't
but um yeah her selling shirts would not
even it wouldn't make my list
right right right there's just so much
that like that that i see actually
that's a big weakness the right needs to
to get past too two
well the right and the left should
absolutely
they're a bunch of lefty youtubers and i
see the stuff they produce
and i see how they like they hit a wall
and they can't grow their channels and
i'm like bro you make videos talking
about youtubers
criticizing this guy for being right
wing or whatever and then making fun of
him make content about the politicians
criticize the politicians who don't like
in the policies they're enacting stop
wasting your time on you know e-drama
stuff like that
we need to actually i think everybody on
youtube we might disagree on hard policy
uh in many ways but i think most of the
people on youtube disagree with the
establishment
and and and this cronie machine that has
kept out
actual leaders yeah how many how many
like let me ask you your opinion cause
if you told if you asked me
how many people in congress do i think
um actually
represent the people i'd probably say
like three maybe
um how many do you think definitely less
than ten
uh i i don't know the exact number i
will tell you this is interesting though
because the progressive caucus
has like over 100 members in it in
congress right and it turns out you
pay to be in the progressive caucus so
it's like 4 000 or whatever it is
and so there is an inordinate amount of
people then that i'm i'm curious that i
would love to ask them
so i see that you consider yourself a
progressive how come you've never called
medicare for all for a floor vote like
where have you been on that why are you
not doing that are you i guess you're
not really progressive you just paid to
be called one
so so the amount of actual people i mean
and i could
like my favorite person is katie porter
i'm a katie porter fan um
nobody sticks it to the corporate
criminals as the way she does but
i don't know a handful maybe handful of
people that are legitimately
representing constituents and not
corporate donors
i say zero rand paul um debatable you
don't have only politicians
you heard me describe politicians
politicians are big buttoxes all of them
are filled with certain stuff somebody
left someone filled it more let's just
be honest even us as citizens
we're all sucking on this program that
where the federal reserve's giving us
fiat currency we're getting we have
their slave labor overseas that make our
iphones
like our chocolate comes from like child
slaves
human trafficking we're in this system
and we complain about it some of us do
rightfully so but we're still part of it
these these clothing were built in like
factories in china well people are
trying to change that
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go
live don't forget to subscribe hit the
like button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time